and all of a sudden i i saw to myself
i'm just 10 minutes away from tel aviv
which is a hub for technology innovation
startups companies
and i became very curious to to learn
more about
this phenomena and to meet those people
to understand what they are doing
moisture friedman thank you for joining
me are you ready to have some fun
sure of course thanks for having me such
a great honor
i i'm honored to have the last time we
saw each other was it
in dubai and just about a month ago i
believe uh
and besides that we've been in touch for
quite some time because you really are
one of the most inspirational figures in
the tech ecosystem in israel that i can
think of particularly because
of your background and the things that
you're doing with the community besides
just helping
people build great technology and great
products you're really helping people
transform lives and and
changing outlooks and and engagements
between communities
so without me giving an introduction
about you moishe i want to go
all the way back to your childhood talk
to me about your upbringing
obviously you're dressed a little bit
differently than most guests on my show
and i want to talk about that too openly
so tell me a little bit about who you
are and and what are you even doing here
in technology
okay so again thanks for having me such
a great honor and pleasure
and so my childhood i grew up
in jerusalem born and raised in
jerusalem
in a haredi community already it's a
ultra orthodox
i prefer to use the term haredi this is
the term people
use in israel it's the ultra religious
ultra orthodox community in israel
in fact my great-grandfather
a 120 years ago he was the founder
of the ultra orthodox community
orthodox movement in israel he was a
very famous rabbi
his name was joseph heim zonefeld you
can google him
he was a very famous rabbi a lot of
books
written about him a lot of stories and
he came from eastern europe and he
established the entire ultra-orthodox
movement in israel
he was very religious and then what
motivated him
was to he believed that his mission is
to keep
the jewish religion the jewish tradition
uh when it faced you know with the
modern world
the science the modern
culture the the modern education
uh it is his thought is the mission is
to keep
the religious community and the
religious
tradition so we started the
ultra-orthodox movement
which was a movement which is a movement
of
people that were really really very
religious
and especially he put a lot of emphasis
on the
education system he believed that
the education system should be pure
religions so he didn't didn't want that
the
ready kids will study you know
science mathematics languages because
he he was afraid that if they will get
um
you know for example languages they will
be
exposed for you know to outside infrared
so he thought he you can think about it
virtually he built the
walls around the community
and he said we want to be inside the
walls we don't want anything
outside the walls to get in
and put our children
under a different influence this was
and lo and behold here you are moishe
leading helping entrepreneurs lead
hundreds of software technology
companies running hackathons
and exposing thousands if not hundreds
of thousands of youth
and that have those walls to information
into
this world so how does that happen
so for exa first of all i don't think i
may you know
fighting against my great-grandfather
i believe that the walls are good things
but i'm trying to be the bridge
between our community and outside
the outside world i believe that maybe
the walls are good but
we need definitely bridges between the
communities
i'm trying to build these bridges and i
will explain you know
how how come i know i i get to to do
this
um so i grew up in this community and
just to give you a few numbers you know
uh when they started it was before the
state of israel
the kharadi community was a very small
community a few hundreds of families
in jerusalem in particular
and then under this langtail
today is a haredi community in israel
something about 1 million people wow
percent of population and when you are
looking at kids in israel today
27 percent of the kids
in first grade in israel are ultra
orthodox hereditary
27 so this same
you know community this part of
population is growing very very fast
and will be a major part of
you know it's already a major part but
it will become
more and more a bigger part in the
population in israel
27 percent it's a lot and when
we are looking at the future of israel
it's not the far future it's
the near future we should ask ourselves
how we know israel is a startup nation
it's a nation of
you know science technology innovation
startups
and if you have a almost one-third of
the kids
that are not studying computers
and science uh if israel will be or
remain the startup nation or right we
will face a different israel in the
future
uh so i grew up in a very religious
family
in a rabbinical family in fact
all my you know grandfathers are rabbis
all my uncles are rabbis my father is a
big rabbi
and um my you know i got the education
to become a rabbi
my mother wants me to be a big rabbi
and she raised me to be a big rabbi
and still waiting for me to become a big
rabbi
but um right i'm ow i'm now
around 40 years old somehow 10 years ago
when i was a 30 years old on my way to
to become a big rabbi maybe um
i re i one day i brought a computer
because i wrote a few books and i was
very
i wanted to to write books and i i
needed a computer to write
those books it was a la allahic books
religious books right i published a few
books
and ended the computer the computer was
connected
to the internet and all of a sudden
i start you know browsing the internet
and realizing
a lot of very interesting stuff
about the outside world right
you know i was very focused in my
childhood and my
youth around the religious and the
religious studies
i grew up a very religious family and
they studied in yeshivat and
you know i was very happy so i i had a
wonderful childhood the wonderful youth
a lot with a lot of you know mission and
purpose in life
to become a big rabbi and a big
scholar and everything was amazing you
know
very you know loving family and a lot of
good friends and community
with a lot of joy and happiness nothing
nothing bad about my you know background
only good words
but um somehow i was very focused
around the religious and the you know
being a religious leader
and all of a sudden when i brought the
computer and the internet i realized
that
i'm living in israel which is a country
of innovation
technology science and at the time i was
living in the
neighborhood i moved from i grew up in
jerusalem
when i got married i moved to nebraska
and my wife
she is from neighborhood and then the
neighborhood is just
10 minutes away from tel aviv and all of
a sudden
i i saw to myself i'm just 10 minutes
away
from tel aviv which is a hub for
technology innovation startups companies
and i became very curious to to learn
more about
this phenomena and to to meet those
people
to understand what they are doing and i
just
you know took my car and drove to tel
aviv
10 minutes away started to participate
in
events meetups lectures you know tel
aviv it's
very vibrant right city of
innovation and a lot of activities
around this
all the time you have you know events
conferences
every day and before the covey of course
and so i i participated in also a lot of
those events
i really felt that i fell in love with
technology
with innovation and with the ideas that
you know we can change the world we can
build
new products new platforms and create
you know
innovation bring knowledge connect
people
all those phenomenas i really become
fascinated by it
and become very enthusiastic about the
all this and then just
a few months later i came
one day to my brother my younger brother
and told him
we are building a startup
he thinks you're crazy he thought i'm
crazy he said
what is a startup i told him we will
figure out
uh i don't love that i play no i really
want to be to build a startup i have so
much
passion and you know curious about this
world
let's try together to build a startup we
had
no education no connections you know
we grew up in israel we had a lot of
religious education
zero a technology you know
no background in technology business
nothing we even
didn't spoke english only you know pbc
um but we had so much a passion
and this is at 30 years old right moishe
we're talking about 30 years old
30 years old and we were very motivated
to do something amazing my brother is
amazing and we
you know we said let's let's try to
build a startup even though we didn't
know
nothing about it you know we didn't come
from
you know a network of you know 8 200 a
technion you know university nothing
just a lot of passion and then
we started a company called clip-up it
was a video editing
online you know imagine 10 years ago
it was a big a big deal though the in
the video emerged and you know
to create tools to edit video online to
share video online online
when we started we realized that there
is another company
in our field called the kaltura they
just started at the time
i might have heard of them so they
become a few
a billion dollar company or more but
at the time we say oh there is a
competitor kaltura
so and then we find another competitor
magisto a few competitors you know
we started at the time that to build a
video platform
online video to share video to edit it
it was a good idea
at the time um but so as the idea was
good i think but
we were apparently not
the best entrepreneurs in town well
moishe i think
it says a lot that you chose to pursue a
product
with that that seems to be the right
product in the right timing with with
two
fantastic names that you mentioned that
i'm good friends with both and
and so obviously i think i think the
power of an entrepreneur
just as much as it is the execution it's
also to understand the product and what
needs to be done and also when it needs
to be done and it sounds like you hit
those two out of those three which is
more than already most entrepreneurs but
just to give it a little bit of a taste
to people who don't know you as well as
i do moishe give me
a little bit let's fast forward a little
bit and then go back
what's happening today how many you're
working on
on various initiatives if you had to
estimate how many different
karate charades you've you've touched
and you've
you've sort of been in contact with and
how many people have gone through your
different initiatives
what is the scale of your work today
because it's it's huge
yeah so if i need to fast forward today
uh i think we touched every year a few
thousands of uh radium
incredible so we have various various
programs in
we have education program where we teach
computer science
and bring is graduates to the best
companies like apple
google microsoft facebook checkpoint
western digital cisco etc
we have in this program 2 000 students
every year wow
i think we are today the largest uh
a program to teach computer science in
israel
i think i'm not sure definitely in in
the
radio world you know but i think in
israel in general
two thousand students and again i just
want to put things in perspective
moisture because a lot of people
have these you know these lessons and
these courses around the world for
different communities but
here you're actually talking about a
community that wouldn't get exposed to
this if it weren't for you
i mean this is a huge mitzvah isn't it
i feel it's a big mitzvah i will tell
you
something about it in a minute i just
want to to finish the story with one
anecdote
you know i went you know around with my
startups the video startup and then one
day i met
jose valdez who is a very famous
entrepreneur in israel
very famous i met him in a conference
and i told him you see
i have a startup maybe want to invest in
my startup
he looked at me he said you are ready
i said yes he said i never saw in my
life
already entrepreneur he was at the time
70 years old today
is 80 years old he said i never saw a
ready
entrepreneur in my life i said okay but
here i am standing in front of you he
said i can't believe it
already you cannot build a startup you
don't have the education to build a
startup you don't have the culture
and the rabbis they will not allow you
to build a startup
i can't imagine and we started you know
to
to argue around this and then he told me
he said so we we started the
conversation about horadine
not for radium you know in israel it's a
big issue
the society is very polarized and all
the issues around
religion and state it's a it's a big
deal in israel in politics and in the
society
so we started arguing about it and then
i told him
he told me i want to to say to tell you
something
you know you are walking now in the
field of video he said
i don't know if you're a big expert or
not in video and what
will be your contribution to the world
in the field of video
but the idea that you should follow is
you should build another starter the
startup of
bringing the haradium into the high tech
if you will manage to take your
community which is
the fastest growing community in israel
and bring
them into the new economy
into the you know give them the
education bring them into the high-tech
industry
bring them to become part of the itec
ecosystem this will be
the biggest startup in israel and if you
are going to do this i want to help you
and i will
help you to build this startup so i need
a pivot
which is i believe pivot is one of the
key words in the world of
you know innovation in startups you
start in
one direction and then you understand
different things and you do a pivot so i
did a pivot
i left the video startup and i started
the
you know social startup to to bring the
charadium into the high-tech industry
and what we are doing is separated to
in general to three different arms one
hour
is really to give education so we
started education program
and then i believe by the way you know
thanks to
today's you know technologies and
platforms
everything become much more easy right
so
in the past if you wanted to give the
best education you need to take saharani
out of the
neighborhood of jerusalem bring him to
the university
and it's very you know complicated right
today
you can bring the best education into
neighborhood into
jerusalem you know we sit here and
discuss
other video you can bring the best
lecturers
the best professors in the world to
teach computer science so we started a
program
we're bringing the best computer science
uh
courses from all over the world to teach
people in neighborhood in jerusalem we
teach them and then we help them find
jobs in the best companies
this is one one part the second part is
entrepreneurship i'm a big believer in
entrepreneurship
i believe that you know a few
entrepreneurs really can change the
world
and if we will find the few great
entrepreneurs
they will change the horizon society
they will bring yes
build companies so and by the way i must
say
to thank amnon professor amnon the
founder of mobiley
who is a huge supporter of kamatech and
he always
keep pushing me and say you should build
the next haredi
entrepreneurs the next horadians that
you will build weeks ways
yeah should come from the haredi
community
so we started um entrepreneurship
program
and by the way i was very inspired by
john chambers the ceo of cisco
is also a supporter of our program in
cisco and john chambers
and john told me once he said in the
past if you wanted to build a company
you need at least one million dollar in
your pocket
just to start you know to write the code
to build the servers
etc you needed at least one million
dollar he said today
when you know we have all the
infrastructure all the cloud computing
all the open source code and everything
you have a lot of tools he said with
five thousand dollars you can start a
company
right yeah just a laptop and you know a
table and you sit somewhere even not a
table you know on on the beach or
somewhere and you can start a company
amazing and i was inspired so much by it
and i told amazon joshua
and he said okay let's bring haredi
entrepreneurs let's give each one of
them five thousand dollars
and let's help them start the companies
and we started the karma tech
accelerator
and they give each entrepreneur five
thousand dollars and
we give them you know all the network
and the connections they need
uh to become successful and bob hashem
this program
become a good program thanks god and
thanks you know all the supporters
and since then we
we met 1 500 already
entrepreneurs
wow that wants to build companies
they can't say i have an idea i have a
team i want to be the company
just numbers are amazing we can't help
everyone of course so we we chose every
year
just 10 entrepreneurs that we thought
will be the best
we gave them whatever they needed and so
far we established
50 companies and all together they're
employing more than 1 000
employees and they raised together over
200 million dollars
already wow so it's really you can call
it
the silicon staten you know it's like a
where uh locating in neighborhood it's
like the silicon valley and silicon
state in nebraska
i love that by the way i think one of
the
most proud proud moments for me was two
weeks ago that
one of our companies called elemento
which is a startup started in comatech
and
it's like a platform for like
weeks or something there today
they nominated to be the second best
startup in israel
in general so you know to imagine that
already entrepreneurs becomes maybe the
second best entrepreneurs in the country
just a few years you know later it's i
think it's unbelievable
and then i really feel that you know
um there is a lot of um
will from a lot of young people from our
community
they want to be a part of you know
it's a new generation they want to be
part of israel
part of the future part of the
innovation technology they want to be
part of it
they believe in this power they still
want to be you know
religious they want to keep their
religious
you know beliefs and values but they
want to to participate
right and we were maybe the right people
in the right time
to build those bridge between all the
haredi community
and the israeli innovation ecosystem
thanks to all the platforms we have
today we can
give people the best education give
people the best opportunities
and we see you know already people
they're getting
you know education they work in google
or facebook or microsoft
they're building startups right and it's
growing so fast
and then you you said it's a big myth
but i must tell you that one time one
day
i went with professor amnon joshua
to meet one of the biggest rabbis in
israel
and he asked this rabbi what he thinks
about what we do if it's okay
if it's good or bad so the rabbi said
we believe that to give someone
education and give him the opportunity
to you know to earn a living and to
become successful it's the biggest the
highest
it's the car you can do you know you
don't just give
someone it it's the car but you give him
you know the tools to become successful
and to help
himself he said it's the biggest mitzvah
someone can do
he said at the time but he wants that
you know the the brightest you know
minds
will be rabbis he said you will take the
second best you know the
the best minds will be in the shiva will
become rabbis
and you can take the second best and
they can build startups
we said okay we agree we will we'll take
it
we will take it you know we'll take this
deal
unbelievable it's really it's really
phenomenal and i have to say that one of
the
one of the you know the most amazing
moments that i've experienced
one of them is here is when i visited
your
uh one of your hackathons in ampersand
i remember that i was sitting with a
group of girls that were working on a on
an idea and the idea was how do we take
kosher phones kosher cell phones that
don't have access to the internet
and we provide information through them
and make information accessible in a
similar way
to the way it's accessible today and one
of the ideas was to use some api
to send sms send a question and then
have that api
you know talk to google or whatever and
then send back an sms response
so sort of you know bridging the wall uh
or building a bridge over the wall uh
because
it it it it is mind-boggling how you
have different communities
within the startup nation that live in
in in you know radically different lives
but then
having a group like the one that you're
building here
that is already transforming both their
lives but at the end it's going to also
be
fundamental to the state of israel right
it's not just about
those thousands of hawaii's that you're
that you're changing their lives it
really is about
the the nation as a whole and bridging
the gap between two communities and i
think that i that that's how
you know that for me that's a very happy
note to end this on it i'm very hopeful
due to the work that you're doing
and i can't wait to work with kubernetes
i can't wait to collaborate them build
startups with them invest in them
get invested by them i i really can't
wait for that day where it's
where it's just a common thing
everywhere around israel
and on that note i really want to thank
you for taking the time to be here with
me
it's really special for me to have you
here and thank you for all the work that
you're doing
before we leave i need three words that
you would use to describe yourself
first of all it was a great pleasure it
was too short
wait it's always too short
but thanks for the opportunity three
words
one i think a curiosity
i think a curio curiosity is very
important you know
i personally i feel i'm curious person i
want
all the time to learn new things to meet
new people
to understand you know different
cultures new technologies new ideas
yes i think curiosity is a key to to
create a better future for all of us
and second i believe in a passion
i believe people need to do things that
they are passionate about
you know to to feel that you love what
you do
if someone doing something that it
doesn't like it and
passionate about it you will never be
successful yes
you should really be passionate about
what you do and if you if not
uh find what is your passion and do it
and then number three three i really
believe in a persistence
you know a you know i think a
change is not easy it's not easy to
change the world
to create new things to build companies
to be entrepreneurial it's not easy
right there's a lot of ups and downs and
it's like a roller coaster you face a
lot of difficulties a lot of challenges
you need to be very persistent to
believe in what you do
and keep going all through all the
you know difficulties and eventually if
you are
entrepreneur you'll be you will be
successful i must say
that i heard once very interesting thing
from a
joram tits the head of errands yeah in
israel
told me amazing thing he said you know
the statistics
are that most of the startups they fail
you know all right
90 they fail but
most of the entrepreneurs succeed
eventually
entrepreneur is building a startup we
fail building another startup you fail
eventually it will become successful
so most of the people that choose the
path of entrepreneurship
they will become successful eventually
so if maybe
most of the ventures fail but most of
the people that
pursuing ventures entrepreneurs they
become
successful so and i think on that note
as well uh
100 it's about persistency
entrepreneurship is not a one-time thing
i'm an entrepreneur for the next six
months that's it it's a mentality that
you take with you throughout your life
and uh i i love that i love that
reasoning a lot
most ventures fail but most true
entrepreneurs don't
i love that moishe thank you very very
much this was wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy such a
great pleasure and i'm looking forward
to hosting you for a really chulant in
nebraska
i would love that very soon
bye